In 1991,
after several years of negotiations in a
whole lot of tension,
the Baltic states,
Lithuania,
Latvia,
Estonia,
I finally managed to break away from the
Soviet Union.
They finally have the freedom that
they've wanted for so then 50 years have
passed since the soldiers of the Red
Army occupying these countries.
During the years under the Soviets.
Repression and fear were the basic
ingredients in the lives of the people
in Estonia,
Latvia,
and Lithuania.
Let's now have a look at some pretty
alarming data.
In Lithuania alone,
a country of little more than two point
5 million people.
These numbers were recorded.
200,000 people were arrested,
questioned and imprisoned.
One hundred and 32,000 people were
deported,
especially to Siberia.
Seventy 5,000 prisoners,
deportees and partisans were eliminated
by the Soviet regime
and of all of that wasn't enough at the
time of their independence.
Poverty and shortages were everyday.
Reality is for all of the inhabitants of
these countries.
I remember the days when the counters at
the shops and to Lynn were empty and the
people were starving.
Economy,
more or less had to be rebuilt from
scratch.
Since then,
if you have things have changed a lot
more than I lost.
In fact,
from the very moment these countries
regains their independence,
they decided to bet it's all on
democracy and freedom.
They were calling me today,
some of the freest ones.
They are members of the EU and NATO and
they prosper today.
These are countries with very high
standards of living and they can really
be considered rich countries.
The transformation it really has been
total and remark
that
they suffered along with the rest of the
world is through the financial crisis
and it really seemed as if their
economies were on the verge of collapse.
Economy contracts almost 18 percent in
the fourth quarter of 2009,
but against all odds,
they manage to recover in a very short
period of time.
Indeed,
they became an example to other
countries like Spain,
Greece,
and Portugal,
but that's a whole different thing that
we're going to talk about being the
future video.
In this video,
we're going to focus on Lithuania and
talk about a problem that is shared by a
lot of the countries in eastern Europe.
I problem that today is actually one of
the biggest threats to them.
Future brain drain
history of Lithuania.
All of the Baltic states in general
since their freedom in 1991.
Well,
it's a history of success today.
They are modern open countries with
prosperous economies.
As with any good story.
Not Everything is quite so pretty.
Yes.
That all issues these countries are
facing and today we're going to
particularly focus on Lithuania in this
country.
The biggest problem is brain drain.
Yep.
That's emigration with an e and this is
no small problem for the country.
Okay.
Since 2004,
when the country was integrated into the
EU,
mania has lost more than 10 percent of
its population.
That is more than 300,000 people,
especially young people have decided to
pack up and move to a different country.
Most of those have chosen to move to the
United Kingdom.
Yeah.
While in western Europe and the United
States,
they aren't concerned about immigration
in Lithuania.
It is the other way around.
They are concerned about people leaving.
They are worried that this might end up
capitalizing the company.
Nineteen 90.
We have lost about 800,000 people in for
a small country.
This is a huge loss.
We're losing our youngest and brightest
and in the future we'll just have old
people who will be dying.
We will have a dying society
and there's always the ones who are
leaving tend to be the most capable and
best prepared to young people.
There's,
of course has a significant impact on
the country's economy.
The number of young people working
decreases talent leaves the country and
as the population ages,
but this is not just a problem for
Lithuania.
The early 19 nineties,
some $20 million of central and eastern
Europe's most talented workers have left
and they have headed largely to western
Europe.
So who do you think has benefited from
all of this?
Talent redistribution.
Yup.
You got that right.
It's the wealthiest countries and that
is why we have to be careful about the
messages being sensed by politicians who
are attempting to criminalize
immigration in order to get votes.
Yes,
we're looking at you to reason me and
Donald Trump,
but I mean I know what you're thinking.
If the Baltic countries have been so
successful,
why are people leaving?
Well because they all looking out for
their own personal success.
For one,
these countries have managed to develop
a well prepared young population who can
also speak English to you must haves
when it comes to looking for a future in
another place and then we also have the
fact that because of all the growth that
has happened since 1991,
these people that can now leave the
country in a comfortable way,
but there is still the key questions you
want sell.
Why are they leaving if things aren't
going so well?
Well,
that's not really that hard to explain.
No
salaries have improved a lot in the last
several years.
The difference between the wealthiest
countries is still quite big.
As an example,
while the average salary in Lithuania is
about 800 euros in United Kingdom,
it is almost 2,500 euros or three times
more.
All of this.
Well,
I might leave you wondering whether this
impressive economic developments was
actually good for the Baltic countries.
Well,
we would say that overall,
yes,
it's certainly worth it's,
but it does leave us with a couple of
very important questions.
Well,
the first one is what is the cost of all
of this and seconds,
how can they stop?
The brain
drank
putting an end to emigrate.
Sure.
So stopping this brain drain,
it's become a pretty major priority for
Eastern European countries.
Some of these countries like Poland,
Latvia,
and Hungary,
they have started a return campaign in
order to persuade immigrants to come
back home.
Welcome all Polish people who went
abroad.
If only they could come back,
it would be a great day for Poland.
Okay.
However,
while this,
it's a nice sentiment.
It is definitely in Lithuania where
there is a larger concern about the
brain drain that the has been more
significant support from society.
The last parliamentary elections
celebrated in October.
The Lithuanian Greens and Farmers Union
won the elections and took control of
the government.
Is pinterest party had only one MP in
the previous elections.
Their main promise,
putting an end to immigration,
but well,
of course this is easier said than done,
so the question is how is this party
going to succeed?
Policy,
leds,
by the way,
by Ramina Cabal Skus,
one of the most important businessmen in
the country,
well apparently their top priority is to
stop immigration by attracting much more
foreign investments.
They claim that if they can succeed in
getting more foreign money for
investment,
they will be able to provide a more jobs
with higher salaries so well,
how are they planning to do this well,
by reducing bureaucracy,
chasing corruption,
and also by making adjustments to the
labor markets.
And the truth is that this does make a
ton of sense and we could say that the
Baltic countries really do seem to know
how to get things done.
Let's hold on for just a second because
this.
It's not the end of the story.
There are some other things that,
well,
they don't look quite so good.
The shadows of the Lithuanian plan
on the one hands.
At the same time as the government
promised foreign investments,
they have also committed to raise taxes
by eliminating what is known as a flat
tax look in Lithuania as well as in
Estonia and not be at the tax systems.
Really symbol in Lithuania case.
There is this flat tax which is a rate
of 15 percent for people and companies.
That is to say that the Lithuanian who
makes $10,000 pays $1,500 in taxes,
was the one who makes 10 times more at
100,000 euros,
also pays 10 times more,
read 15,000 euros.
Raising taxes in this way sort of goes
against the foreign investments and
higher salaries plan and this rise will
direct harm both of those things,
and by the way,
corporate taxes,
they're not as low as they might seem.
If we up the social
security contributions and other taxes,
companies pay more than 40 percent of
their gross profits in taxes according
to the World Bank.
Now,
we also have to point this out.
The issue of Russia and NATO,
the previous Lithuanian governments and
the current is no exception.
I've insisted on scaring the population
and also the rest of the world with the
Russian threat thing that the country is
constantly in danger.
Okay.
Now,
while it is true that the threats are
real,
it's not really a brilliant way to
instill confidence in potential
investors,
and finally,
and maybe most importantly of all,
that is a cultural matter that affects
the entire country.
So you might want to write if this,
this brain drain going on,
wouldn't it be logical to try and
compensate for this by bringing in young
professionals from other countries?
Well,
that's kind of a problem because this
country,
it's also a bit suspicious about
immigration.
Most of these countries,
a touch nationalist anyway,
if anything is full session,
is that Lithuania is rather this stonier
in Latvia have done their homework and
is that policies are certainly much more
efficient than the ones that predominate
in the rest of Europe.
Remember,
in 25 years they have managed to become
rich countries with higher standards of
living.
Well,
now we'd like to know what you think.
Do you think these countries will
finally be able to stop this brain
drain?
Well,
we're looking forward to hearing what
you think in the comments section below,
and as always,
if you like this video,
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe if you haven't
already for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and don't forget to
check out the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that aren't mine,
and as always I'll see you in the next
video.